welcome to an all new state of play
we've got more than 15 minutes of new
ratchet and clank rift apart ps5
gameplay coming right up
but first let's check in on two other
exciting games coming to playstation 4
and playstation 5 consoles this year
made it to 4546b landing was
a bit rough but i don't think they've
spotted me
hi i'm jeff audio producer at unknown
worlds
set one year after the award-winning
original subnautica below
zero plunges players into a frigid
underwater adventure in search of
answers
here the native wildlife above and below
the surface might consider you a tasty
tree
assuming you don't become an ice pop
first the previous research crew has
vanished including your sister this was
sam's necklace she never took it off
to uncover the truth you'll need to get
crafty building tools and shelter for
your survival
but even that may not be enough
i told you to stay off my land with the
ps5 dual sense controller
every ic shock feels like it's being
sent right into your hands
the haptic feedback system allows you to
feel each adrenaline filled chase
and provides visual and audio cues as
you use resources
encounter key game moments or get into
situations where it's
probably best to run by the time you
squint to see what's ahead it may
already be too late
fortunately when you play below zero on
ps5
players will get a crystal clear
experience with up to 4k
graphics targeting 60fps when in
performance mode
and if you already own a physical or
digital version of the first subnautica
on ps4
you'll be able to upgrade to the digital
ps5 version at no
additional cost we hope you're as
excited as we are to dive into the world
of subnautica below zero when it
launches on ps5
and ps4 on may 14th
[Music]
we can't wait to dive deep into
subnautica below zero
and make baseless accusations against
our crewmates in among us later this
year
looks like ratchet and the gang are
ready for the spotlight next up
insomniac games will lead us on a tour
of this june's ps5 action adventure
is
[Music]
[Music]
i'm marcus smith creative director of
ratchet and clank rift apart a brand new
full-length ratchet and clank adventure
built from the ground up for the
playstation 5 console
today we're going to introduce you to
some of the gameplay characters
and arsenal of rift apart whether you've
played every game since ratchet and
clank's debut or you're brand new to the
series
rift apart is a stand-alone adventure
that you won't want to miss
let's get into it
clank clank
what is this place
where are you clank maybe someone around
here has seen him
have any of you seen a little grey robot
anywhere green eyes red antenna
very charming
ratchet has been separated from his best
friend and partner clank
and is now in a new dimension and a
mysterious urban sprawl
called nefarious city
[Music]
[Music]
please let there be good news behind
here
ratchet quickly finds out that in this
dimension dr nefarious is a much more
capable villain
welcome to the nefarious city bazaar
please remember to thank our
marvelous emperor before during
and after making your purchase
emperor does that mean there are two
nefariouses now
clink first nefariously maybe he's in
this bazaar thanks to the new hardware
the worlds and rift apart are more
beautiful than ever
cities are full of life with traffic and
civilians milling about everywhere
rift apart is full of the unexpected
characters in this new dimension are not
always the same as they were in ratchet
and clank's dimension
ratchet comes across miss zerkont the
weapon vendor in rift apart
wait a second you forgot your order
come right in
weapons but you gotta be less
conspicuous
or the resistance will not last
the resistance
oh apology sugar
miss sircon is still new to all of this
espionage
flank has been taken by a mysterious new
lombax
named rivet clank
no i need to go after that ship
how can i get off planet it's a test
only royal starships are allowed to
leave
anything else
phantom can help just follow the bait to
club nefarious and you will find
him club nefarious got it oh and nice
work secret agent zircon
this is so exciting
club nefarious shouldn't be hard to miss
better look around
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so that sounds like a club all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
once ratchet finds phantom he learns a
couple of new moves
[Music]
one of the focal points of gameplay in
rift apart is increased mobility
ratchet can now dash and wall run to
traverse levels
this focus on mobility allows players to
chain moves together to create
exhilarating humps
now let's jump into combat nefarious day
spa
if you can distract these troopers i'll
hack the fairies as propaganda blimp and
give this city a message it'll never
forget
looks easy enough
dashing allows you to evade attacks or
gain strategic advantages
enemies can't hit what doesn't
momentarily exist
dimensional tears in the world allow you
to use the rift tether
another new traversal mechanic to
instantly pull yourself across
battlefields to escape or flank enemies
weapons in rift apart utilize the power
of the dual sense wireless controller's
adaptive triggers and haptic feedback to
allow players to really feel the power
of their arsenal
for example with the burst pistol
players can pull back the trigger part
way
to peck out accurately placed single
shots but pulling the trigger fully
unleashes a rapid fire spread that
covers more area
in either case players will feel each
shot burst from the weapon and connect
with enemy
with the enforcer players can pull the
trigger down halfway to fire a single
barrel
reducing time between reloads or pull
the trigger fully
and unleash both barrels with a
devastating close range attack
thanks to the haptics the player will
feel the power of their shots through
their hands
let's move ahead a little bit
as ratchet attempts to follow rivet and
clank he encounters a nefarious
juggernaut
where did you even come from
[Music]
during this fight more dimensional chaos
ensues
thanks to the power of the ssd we can
near instantly teleport players to
completely different locations
this isn't some small arena being loaded
but the entire level
from a different planet
let's jump over and see what's going on
with rivet and clank
as you may have guessed rivet is a brand
new playable character in the series
where are you taking me i was gonna take
you to my hideout
but first i gotta rescue my friends at
their gelatonium factory
rift apart includes several alternate
dimension versions of classic planets
from past games
[Music]
did we mention how stunning and alive
our worlds are
thanks to the power of the ps5 and the
3d audio we've been able to create
alien planets with an immersive density
like never before
let's check it out speedles yeah that's
why i'm gonna ride one
as soon as i can get close enough back
to ms zircon
the weapons vendor this wasn't what was
in my account last time
oh that is because i added our
mutual friend on nefarious city
okay in rift apart you get to play with
an explosive
new arsenal as well as a few returning
[Music]
classics
sweet things
here's another example of how we're
using the dual sense with the topiary
sprinkler
players will feel resistance in the
trigger as they prepare a throw of this
garden grenade
once on the ground and spitting out its
rapid growth plant fertilizer
players will also feel when enemies have
been topiaried
and are ready to be trimmed down
it appears some dimensional distortion
is emanating from that
in addition to rift tethering and
dimensional shifts there are also many
pocket dimensions scattered throughout
the game
and the last needle runs into that rift
thingy interesting you must have a rift
tether in your glove
too
all right smarty bot what is this place
i
um a dimensional pocket
perhaps a symptom of the dimensionator's
destruction
how do you come up with this step
hey it's maynard the mortz's helper bot
must have wandered in through the rift
somehow
there is the speedle
no no don't hide ah hitting its nest
might get its attention
maybe maynard can lead
[Applause]
now if we can get away from this acid
come on maynard
let's find the morts riding speedls is
one way of traversing sargasso's acid
swamps
and to do so quickly excuse me
look out i got it i got it see
sometimes i don't crash
there's the gelatonium factory coming
north
we didn't follow that longbacks in his
robo pet across dimensions
just to get stopped by some fuzz balls
so you got like
nine and a half seconds to tell us where
they're at
one
if you watched our previous gameplay
demo you may recognize the goons for
less
this rebranded gang has been hired by dr
nefarious to attack ratchet and clank
and are now also trapped in rivets
dimension
here's another new weapon the shatter
bomb is a frag type grenade that deals a
lot of damage to your foes
with haptic feedback each explosion
feels incredibly impactful
as well
wow
in my head is freaking hard
this is just a small taste of some of
the early gameplay in rifta park
but there is so much more we have open
areas to explore
dimensional clank puzzles
glitch challenges
arena challenges
[Music]
aerial combat
[Music]
gold bolts to collect pocket dimensions
to explore
[Music]
armor to obtain and use in the first
ever ratchet and clank photo mode
and giving more people access to playing
our games is always important to us
as such rift apart will offer a slew of
accessibility options
we'll reveal more about this soon
experience rift departs new planets
weapons intense high action combat and
near instant load times
all with some of the best visuals we've
ever created
[Music]
these ribs are getting out of hand on
behalf of all of us at insomniac games
thank you for watching
we'll see you in the omniverse on june
11th
that's our show we explored the depths
of an alien ocean
got a first look at among us on
playstation and zipped across space and
time in ratchet and clank
rift apart
thanks for watching we'll see you again
soon
you